In the rainy season, there is food about if you know where to look.
Dead acacia tree.
What the locals will always do with this is to come up and put their ear to it,...
...and listen for larva inside.
Here you go. That's what I mean.
It's a rhino beetle larva.
You can just eat them, even raw.
When they're cooked, they are a bush delicacy.
And at this time of year, there's plenty of them here.
No wonder they fry them.
Oh! Ready for this?
Oh my goodness!
This one has been living in there for a very, very long time.
I'm not gonna need to eat for a week after this one.
Pound for pound, insects like these contain more protein than beef or fish.
They're perfect survival food.
It actually ranks as one of the worst things I have ever, ever eaten.
I tell you, it's like if all your friends got all their bogies together,...
...squeezed them inside a sausage,...
...and then you put that into your mouth, man!